you are the fifth person now including
let's see here dr aubry de gray um
dr robert agemian dr kirill piazzkevich
uh and jonathan keats and now dr rupert
sheldrake
um i'm trying to keep a list of these
people because
you guys are the only people that i know
that do not
own cell phones and
what what you have you have said
well uh i'll say what you know aubry de
gray has called it the ultimate
destroyer of personal solitude
you have said i do not want to be
interrupted all the time
and for example with me this device has
been off
now for quite a long period of time so
that i can finish this project and it's
going to be off
so that i can continue finishing this
project so
will you please briefly speak to
especially the millennial and generation
z
that is now using the devices non-stop
we use them 150 times a day
um we speak to the importance and cal
newport talks a lot about the idea of
deep work
and we've been talking about this for so
long but just the the focus
and neurobiologists are talking about it
now the importance of that focus for
achieving big goals in your life
we just briefly mentioned um talk about
that for a moment
well yes i mean cell phones are
obviously highly convenient and
they're essential for many people's work
life and and so they
obviously have their uses um
but they can easily become a means of
constant distraction
and the whole point of um deeper work is
being able to focus and concentrate and
constant distraction of drip feed of
news and social trivia on facebook and
other social media and
so um it is just ultimately distracting
and
so i think that one one of the things i
suggest actually in
ways to go beyond i have a chapter there
on the importance of holy days and
festivals
um and it was always a tradition
i mean in the jude in the judaic
tradition having the sabbath a day when
you don't work
the whole point of the sabbath is that
you it's a day
it's a holy day a holy day is a holiday
this is the same word
yeah you you it's a holy day because you
don't work
and then the purpose of it is to give
thanks to god
to make love to be with your family to
play music
to have fun and then
for christians it's sunday for muslims
it's friday but there's like this
pattern
of a sabbath the day in the week when
you have we now have a weekend
two days but the trouble is these have
now got engulfed by 24 7 culture
so shopping malls are open or at least
they were until the coved lockdowns
and you know constant amazon deliveries
online shopping 24 7.
this is completely abolished this
necessary
time it's part of human nature to have
time off
together and for people who are forced
to work on sundays because they work in
a shop in a shopping mall for example
then the employer says oh you can have
tuesday off instead that's not the point
because everyone else is working on
tuesday it's it's being together
being alone altogether as one wishes to
have a time away
from all this work life and
the the workaholic culture which america
has
spread to the rest of the world
[Laughter]
procedures i mean america is the place
where it's worst i think workaholism
is really does need something doing
about it for our own sanity
and so i think that the minimum thing
i'd suggest is having as a technological
sabbath i mean ideally on
if you're jewish on saturday if you're
christian from a christian background on
sunday if your muslim background on
friday um
but have have a day when you don't work
when you do
when you do just have time to read books
listen walk in nature do some gardening
hang out with friends make love
uh play music uh you know
and and not be distracted the whole time
so i think that
for people who need these devices for
their work who've become dependent on
them for
earning a living i mean and many people
have um
obviously you can't just give them up
but having a technological sabbath and
actually ideally combining with a real
sabbath
real um holy day once a week
and then observing the festivals i think
it's very important to
most people observe in america
thanksgiving and christmas
um but there are other festivals
throughout the year which are important
and for me
an important one is september the 29th
the feast of st michael and all angels
which is a time
to become aware of all those forms of
consciousness beyond the human level
and the ancients thought that every star
and planet had its own
intelligence which was an angel i mean
they weren't
humanoid beings with wings they were the
intelligences of the celestial bodies
the whole heavens is full of
intelligence in that worldview
and for me the feast of michael and all
angels is a way to connect with all
those forms of non-human
intelligence beyond our own the feast of
the day of the dead
um november the second which is a very
big deal in mexico
and in many catholic countries um is the
feast when we
acknowledge and remember the ancestors
those who've gone before
november the first all saints day all
hallows day
um is when we remember the blessed dead
in the famous dead and
november the second everyone else and
for most people they're just forgotten
about these festivals
instead children remember the eve of
these festivals halloween
um that's become a sort of orgy of
dressing up as witches
and and eating candies and stuff um
but the festival itself has been
hollowed out and
for me again november the second is a
day when i
i always go to a requiem mass uh i
remember
my dead parents and ancestors my dead
friends and all those i know
and who will give thanks for who've gone
before on november 1st
i give thanks to all those who've been
my teachers who are now departed and
who've influenced me
so i think having throughout the year
you see there are these special days the
festivals
each with its own purpose and their
holidays traditionally
um so that there's time to give
attention to these other things
so i think recovering a sense of sacred
time
yes it's very important and switching
off
cell phones uh when one's doing that
is is a very important part of it so i
would say that
starting with special days holy days and
festivals
and then maybe extending it out further
to
only having it on certain hours a day
it would be a good way to go it's not a
good way to go to have one's entire life
engulfed by 24 7 workaholic culture
so well said these technological
sabbaths also these rituals that have
been passed on for so long to have
like you talk about the brief moment
before you dig into your dinner and
with your family just hold each other's
hands and close your eyes and reflect on
the beauty
of the fact that you are sharing a meal
there's so many different ways there's
all these
days that are celebratory days to just
take a sabbath away from
technology and workaholism and just tune
more
inward and music make love
um go play be in nature do art
this is so beautiful and i'm really
happy that
that you listed i i it's gonna be really
important potentially even moving
forward to do things like
just have a have date have more days
where we just
say okay turn down
the economic machinery today and turn
up the spiritual machinery today
we're going to have to have more days
like that in the future that was
beautifully said rupert thank you so
much for coming onto the program and for
uh teaching us everything that you have
today this has been an honor and a
pleasure
we're very grateful thank you oh fun to
be with you alan thank you